[Musica]
io vorrei partire con una domanda così
per provare anche un po degli archi dopo
il pranzo se la scienza lo permettesse
voi quanti anni potreste vivere quanto
lunga dovrebbe essere secondo voi la
vostra vita pensateci un attimo
potete anche rispondermi ma se volete 70
anni 80 100 1000 magari di più non so
come
120 precise ok vabbè rispettabile non so
se vi siete posti mai questa domanda io
sono fatta qualche volta è la risposta
che personalmente mi sono dato è che
sinceramente la domanda non mi interessa
molto mi dispiace per i 120 anni però
ritengo che non sia questa la domanda da
porsi non che non sia prioritario meglio
perché la domanda che veramente secondo
me è rilevante e importante da
affrontare a cui rispondere e come
potrei come potremmo avere una qualità
della vita ottimale quindi essere in
piena salute con al massimo delle nostre
funzioni fino all'ultimo giorno
all'ultimo minuto della nostra vita
questo secondo me è una priorità e penso
quindi di conseguenza che l'umanità deve
concentrarsi sulle sfide giuste quindi
se posso permettermi anche di
ricollegare i metodi stamattina
l'umanità deve affrontare il cambiamento
climatico subito perché è urgentissimo
deve trovare cure per malattie genetiche
che colpiscono bambini milione di
bambini che sono terribili
subito dopo però o meglio ancora in
parallelo a questo deve secondo me
provare a sviluppare tecnologie che
aumentino più possibile la qualità della
vita delle persone e non che la
allunghino quindi noi non l'abbiamo
secondo me bisogno di vivere 100 120
magari sì però non 150 anni 200 anni non
è questo che ci serve ci serve viverla
al meglio e la bioingegneria si occupa
di questo
quindi io insieme a voi vorrei capire un
po come siamo messi a che punto siamo
con queste tecnologie e provare anche a
capire qual è la prospettiva
la città è partirei dal diabete come
primo esempio più di cento anni fa che
si ammalava di diabete e tipicamente
bambini e adolescenti
purtroppo aveva un'aspettativa di vita
ridottissima di pochi giorni di poche
settimane perché non c'era una cura e
poi cento anni fa esattamente cento anni
fa fu scoperta l'insulina e questo
ormone questa invenzione ha salvato la
vita di milioni di persone e
l'aspettativa di vita di fatto oggi per
i pazienti diabetici è paragonabile a
quella dei soggetti non diabetici quindi
potreste pensare che il problema è
risolto non certo da fare niente già 100
anni fa era stato risolto ma non è così
perché questa questo allungamento
dell'aspettativa di vita a un costo di
fatto è questo costo è la necessità di
aderire costantemente ama terapia tutti
i giorni senza eccezioni
quindi tutti i giorni senza eccezioni un
paziente diabetico deve bucarsi un dito
far uscire una goccia di sangue
misurare il livello di glucosio nel
sangue e poi iniettarsi una certa con
precisa quantità di insulina tipicamente
con punture nella pancia con dosatori
cose del genere e capite bene che si può
fare meglio cioè la tecnologia può
migliorare la qualità della vita di
queste persone e bisogna puntare a
questo quale l'ottimo qual è il sogno di
un bioingegnere in questo campo il sogno
sarebbe di avere diciamo degli omini
miniaturizzati immaginiamo cieli così
che stiano all'interno del corpo che
facciano tutto loro che risolvono il
problema che facciano quello che fa
l'organo naturale sano e che noi non ce
ne accorgiamo neanche quindi che non
interferiscono in nessun modo con la
nostra vita è un po a che punto siamo
con questi omini negli anni 70
sono stati introdotti per la prima volta
ai cosiddetti pancreas e artificiali
erano delle macchine come quella che
vedete qua nell'immagine questa fu la
prima cosiddetto baio state nel 77 che
automaticamente da sole misuravano la
glicemia e iniettavano l'insulina nel
corpo del paziente quindi facevano le
azioni che che dicevo prima quindi
liberavano in qualche modo il paziente
dal mondo averle fare e però da questo
sistema funziona o funziona ma anche
abbastanza bene però aveva un piccolo
difettuccio che magari potete intuire
anche voi che più grande del paziente
stesso quindi altro che miniaturizzato
era un oggetto che era lontanissimo
dall'essere portabile e di fatto usabile
però sono passati i vari decenni oggi
sono nel 2021 e la bioingegneria fatto
dei passi avanti notevoli oggi può anche
asset ufficiali sono fatti così sono
costituiti da elementi come questa pompa
peristaltica che è lei di fatto con un
intelligenza bordo che inietta insulina
automaticamente tramite un tubicino
cateterino transcutaneo che attraverso
la pelle del paziente e rilascia
all'insulina sotto pace quindi
finalmente 2021 problema risolto
possiamo dire che abbiamo ripristinato
la qualità della vita al cento per cento
in parte sì ma siamo lontani dall'avere
una soluzione veramente ottimale per i
pazienti diabetici perché perché questo
cateterino transcutaneo comitato si
infetta quindi va sostituito
periodicamente con dei piccoli
interventi e soprattutto questi sistemi
sono tutti esterni paziente deve badare
continuamente costantemente a questi
sistemi deve starci attento non può fare
ad esempio delle sport non può fare
nuoto non può fare varie cose in modo
almeno spensierato e poi c'è una
questione estetica molti ragazzi e
ragazze non accettano di buon grado
sistemi del genere anche in altri campi
perché di fatto si vedono all'esterno e
non sono ben accettati quindi torniamo
un attimo i nostri omini l'ottimo
sarebbe avere appunto qualcosa che
sparisce completamente all'interno del
corpo e non ce ne accorgiamo neanche che
fa dimenticare al paziente la propria
patologia questo è il sogno però appunto
è un sogno è un'utopia fantascienza
allora diciamo così
il problema è che se io ho un oggetto
impiantato un dispositivo che contiene
insulina di zollino abbiamo detto è da
cent'anni il fallo che usiamo per
contrastare il diabete per ricaricare
questo se il vosto che quando lezione
finisce perché dopo un po finisce come
si fa se impiantato non è che si può
fare un intervento chirurgico milanesi
no
e
allora noi ci siamo inventati sta cosa
un po folle cioè una capsula piena di
insulina e in qualche modo intelligente
che il paziente può inghiottire o
ingerire una volta alla settimana volta
ogni due settimane e lei da sola in modo
autonomo naviga attraverso il tatto
gastrointestinale viene riconosciuta dal
dispositivo impiantato che fa tutto da
solo la cattura è in qualche modo
trasferisce l'insulina la capsula al
serbatoio impiantato ricaricandolo e poi
ovviamente rilasciando la capsula e che
viene poi espulsa potete immaginarvi
insomma come succede questo
e io sono molto ottimista perché questo
non è solo un'idea resto è un prototipo
che abbiamo sviluppato e abbiamo anche
dimostrato che funziona e siamo nel 2021
quindi c'è immagine nei prossimi decenni
per
sicuramente per far diventare questo un
prodotto che puoi usare può migliorare
la qualità della vita di milioni di
pazienti di persone ma io sono sicuro
che nei prossimi 30 anni la
bioingegneria svilupperà sulle soluzioni
analoghe malaja ancora più ambiziose per
una serie di altri organi sto parlando
di reni fegato cuore per i quali
attualmente l'unica soluzione è il
trapianto quindi pensate a quante
prospettive ci sono
e oltre al diabete però ea patologie
simili è opportuno anche concentrarsi
secondo me su patologie che insorgono in
un'età più avanzata
per esempio l'osteoartrite lo start è
una malattia che insorge appunto sono
tipicamente sopra i 50 60 anni e
comporta una forte infiammazione e
degenerazione della cartilagine
cartilagine è un tessuto che diciamo fa
funzionare al meglio le nostre
articolazioni quindi che soffre di
osteoartrite di fatto soffre di una
ridotta mobilità dolore e di una qualità
della vita notevolmente ridotta e per
dare un'idea di quanto è diffusa in
questa patologia
pensate che metà persone sopra i 60 anni
nel mondo metà la metà della popolazione
soffre di vostre artrite quindi
tantissime e sopra gli 80 anni tutte
pressoché tutte le persone soffre di una
forma di artrosi che ne limita la
mobilità e la qualità della vita quindi
è un problema che ha un impatto enorme
nella nostra società che sta l'altro sta
invecchiando rapidamente
e diciamo che in questo campo una
tecnologia che avrebbe un potenziale
enorme è quella delle cellule staminali
cosa sono le cellule staminali cellule
staminali sono
poi tutti sapete che non è il nostro
corpo abbiamo miliardi di cellule molto
specializzate ad esempio i neuroni nel
cervello elaborano informazioni e
controllano anche organi tessuti
e fatto ct nel fegato invece sono delle
specie di centrali chimiche che
producono sostanze utili per il
metabolismo e così via le cellule
staminali invece non sono specializzate
ma tutti noi le abbiamo da un certo
numero di cellule staminali che stanno
lì non hanno un compito specifico però
proprio perché non hanno un compito
specifico hanno il potenziale di ri
generale di diventare qualsiasi cellula
o tessuto del nostro corpo quindi hanno
anche il potenziale di rigenerarlo
questi tessuti sono soggetti a un trauma
una degenerazione
ora lo so detta così sembra un po facile
in effetti non lo è non è assolutamente
così semplice queste cellule non lo
fanno automaticamente da sole e la
bioingegneria riesce a ingegnerizzare
quindi a far capire a queste staminali
cosa devono diventare solo in un numero
molto piccolo di tessuti per esempio la
pelle
però per la cartilagine per esempio non
ci riusciamo non sappiamo quali sono le
istruzioni giuste da dare alle cellule
come se mancassero loro ma casa il
libretto di istruzioni per diventare
tessuto cartilagineo nuovo e noi stiamo
cercando di capire qual è il libretto di
istruzioni come si fa è complicato però
si può fare stiamo studiando dei
nanomateriali quindi degli omini ancora
più molto più miniaturizzati di quelli
di prima addirittura la nanoscala che
insieme a dei materiali intelligenti
possono essere stampati quindi
rilasciati in modo controllato
all'interno dell'articolazione mediante
degli opportuni strumenti chirurgici e
poi solidificati in situ cioè nei punti
in cui serve grazie a uno stimolo
luminoso usando semplicemente la luce a
una certa lunghezza d'onda questi
materiali intelligenti possono essere
frizzati bloccati stabilizzati nel punto
in cui serve una terapia cioè nei punti
in cui la cartilagine degradata e poi lo
stimolo il libretto di istruzioni di cui
parlavamo prima è dato da una specie di
ginocchiera che produce ultrasuoni per
gli ultrasuoni sono gli stessi
ultrasuoni che sicuramente tutti voi
conoscete che si usano per le ecografie
ma diciamo usati in un modo un po
diverso
gli ultrasuoni interesse interagiscono
con questo materiale intelligente di cui
ho parlato riescono a fornire gli
stimoli giusti alle staminali per farle
diventare cartilagine e anche quindi
anche in questo caso dal video abbiamo
visto che i risultati di laboratorio ci
dicono che questo succede davvero che è
un metodo efficace di differenziare le
staminali cartilagine quindi di nuovo io
sono molto ottimista perché ripeto siamo
nel 2021 e pensate quindi a quali
meravigliose frontiere la bioingegneria
di fronte e poi esplorare
ora se pensate che magari la qualità
della vita quello di cui ho parlato non
sia una priorità per voi almeno perché
molti di voi sono giovanissimi
ok libera di pensarlo però tenete
presente che l'età media della
popolazione italiana oggi è di 47 anni
d'eta mettere tutte tutta la popolazione
nel 2050 l'età media di 54 anni quindi
sette anni di più quindi solo 30 anni
noi alzeremmo l'asticella dell'età media
dell'aspettativa di vita di ben sette
anni e questo sarà possibile grazie ai
progressi della medicina però come
dicevo non ci possiamo e non ci dobbiamo
accontentare di questo perché un po
tutti noi dovremo fare i conti con come
vivremo la seconda parte della nostra
vita
e poi pensate insomma quanto sarebbe
bello un mondo in cui nessun anziano
avesse pensieri problemi nell'alzarsi da
una sedia e abbracciare proprio di poter
giocare con lui
infine ecco dopo questo discorso
variegato a sul sulle frontiere della
bioingegneria
alcuni altri di voi potrebbero pensare
va bene ok mi hai convinto tutto bello
bravi viva la scienza però io cosa posso
fare non oltre ascoltare questo vale un
po forse per tutti gli argomenti
poter tifare per la scienza cosa potrei
fare io se non faccio scienza beh
secondo me personalmente potete fare
almeno due cose molto pratiche allora la
prima a prendere le distanze in modo
netto da chiunque proponga soluzioni
magiche scorciatoie soluzioni a problemi
specialmente in ambito sanitario che non
si basano su evidenze scientifiche e qui
ogni riferimento ai novak è puramente
non casuali e la seconda cosa pratica
molto pratica che potete fare è far sì
che fare in modo che tutte le persone
del pianeta possano accedere a queste
tecnologie
e questo diciamo perché la bioingegneria
un po come tutte le tecnologie dovrebbe
essere un bene di tutti quindi se tutti
accederanno o sono una piccola parte la
popolazione accederà a queste a queste
innovazioni
diciamo ancora non è scritto e questo
ovviamente non dipende da noi scienziati
se accadrà o meno dipende dalle scelte
politiche degli stati occidentali dei
prossimi anni ora però noi siamo gli
stati occidentali
voi lo siete e quindi fate sentire la
vostra voce
e insomma sottolineato l'importanza
della ricerca ovviamente ma soprattutto
sottolineare l'importanza che ci sia un
ampia accessibilità a queste tecnologie
in modo che le risorse e le tecnologie
siano distribuiti in modo equo nei
prossimi anni se tutti insieme
lavoreremo verso questo obiettivo sono
sicurissimo che il mondo nel 2050 sarà
un posto molto molto migliore di quello
di oggi grazie
[Applauso]